hi I'm Helen Thompson I'm a producer
here at science news this year for our
year-end issue we decided to ask our
beat writers what they're excited to
cover next year
and here's what they said I'm Emily
Conover I'm the physics writer for
science news so the big discovery this
past year was the detection of
gravitational waves by the light
experiment and we expect to see more
from them in the coming year so that's
really exciting everyone is super pumped
about gravitational waves right now
well particle physics is sort of in a
weird state right now it's it's a little
bit of people are starting to get
anxious and we know that there's a lot
of stuff that's still unexplained in
particle physics like we don't know what
dark matter is the stuff that makes up a
large portion of the matter in the
universe so scientists are starting to
look in some more out-of-the-way corners
for new physics hi I'm Tina Hussman say
and the molecular biology reporter for
science news magazine CRISPR is a hot
new molecular biology tool that you may
have heard of because everybody is using
it to edit genomes
according to most scientists CRISPR can
do anything but it's not exactly true
but it can do a lot of stuff in 2017 you
can expect for instance to see clinical
trials for cancer starting out with
CRISPR and also possibly bringing CRISPR
back to its roots to combat viruses like
HIV and hepatitis I'm Tomas Sumner I'm
the earth and environmental sciences
reporter for science news magazine about
66 million years ago there was a
devastating disaster on earth and about
three-quarters of all plant and animal
species got wiped out in a geologic
incident
and that's been a mystery for decades
and you might have heard in school that
everything died from the space-rock
impact but not everybody believes that
and so help answer that question a team
of researchers has gone back to the
scene of the crime often goes to Mexico
this is giant 200 kilometer across a
crater called Chicxulub they dropped
three giant cow legs into the sea jack
themself out of the waters they had a
stable platform and then drilled
straight down into what's called the
peak ring it's a ring of mountains
within the crater itself so this
drilling project and a lot of other
research projects regarding this
horrible extinction event i've already
told us a lot but there are some big
questions that are remaining and a lot
of the findings are just making those
questions even bigger so 2017 is going
to be interesting one way or the other
whether or not we really solve what
killed the dinosaurs hi I'm Megan Rosen
and I'm a staff reporter at science news
so I cover everything from robots to
dinosaurs but this year I spent a lot of
time focusing on the Zika virus outbreak
so this year we've learned a lot about
how Zika virus can affect a baby's brain
and body but we don't yet have a vaccine
I think the earliest we can expect to
see a vaccine for Zika is in 2018 or
2019 vaccines have already started
working their way through human safety
trials so I'm hoping that we see some
results in 2017 two or three years might
seem like a long time to wait for a Zika
vaccine but in terms of vaccine
development it's a really short timeline
I'm Laura Anders and I'm the
neuroscience writer here at science news
one of the most interesting new
technologies that come across this year
is called mineral dust at these tiny
crystals that scientists can implant and
so far just in animals but they can
eavesdrop on nerve cell behavior and
ultimately they
and control nerve cell behavior
scientists are coming up with all of
these different ways to really figure
out what brain cells are doing and
influence them in a way that might
actually help people hi I'm Christopher
Crockett and I'm the Astronomy writer at
science news it's always a really cool
here to be writing about astronomy
we're always discovering new things and
I'm sure 2017 will be no different but
there are a few things coming up that
I'm really excited about the Juno
mission is at Jupiter and it's been
there since July but now it's gonna
really start doing its regular science
mapping the interior of Jupiter getting
a 3d picture of what the biggest planet
in our solar system is like on the
inside but I think one of the the
coolest things going on in the solar
system this year is the end of the
Cassini mission at the Saturn after
almost 20 years in space and over a
decade at Saturn the missions coming to
an end
the spacecraft is going to dive into
Saturn plunge into its atmosphere as we
making measurements and transmitting
data as long as it can until it's
crushed to death these are just some of
the stories we'll be tracking in 2017
stay tuned to see if we're right and
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
[Music]